مشاهدينا وصول هذه الطائره العسكريه التي
تقل اشخاص وافراد تم نقلهم واجلائهم من
الخرطوم طبعا وصولا الى بورسودان ومن هناك
تم اجلائهم جوا الى مطار عمان حيث نتابع
وصول هذه الطائره التي هي الطائره الخامسه
التي وصلت الى مطار عمان بضمن عمليات
الاجلاء التي تقوم بها الدول لمواطنيها
ورعاياها والدبلوماسيين والبعثات الامميه
وغيرها
اذا تابعنا واياكم مشاهدينا وصول هذه
الطائره الى عمان الى المطار الموجود هناك
المطار الدولي وهي طائره عسكريه لا نعلم
طبعا العدد الموجود على مدن هذه الطائره
ولكن هي الطائره الخامسه ضمن عمليه
الاجلاء التي اطلقتها السلطات الاردنيه
طبعا بموازات عمليات الاجلاء التي اطلقتها
الدول الاوروبيه الدول العربيه وكل
الجاليات الاجنبيه والاماميه التي كانت
موجوده داخل الخرطوم قبل الاشتباكات التي
اندلعت طبعا عمليات الاجلاء كما هو معلوم
ونذكر دائما مشاهدينا تتم برا من الخرطوم
وصولا الى بورسودان ومن هناك يتم نقلهم
اما ببوارج حربيه اي بسفن واما بطائرات
عسكريه
تقلهم الى
الى المكان يعني الذي
يجب ان تذهب اليه الطائره
اذا بدات عمليه انزال الركاب
الذين تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
اصولا الى الاردن
طبعا للتفكير ايضا المسافه التي تفصل بين
الخرطوم وفورتسودان هي حوالي 900 كيلومتر
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن حوالي الخمس ساعات
او 20 ساعه حتى للوصول من هناك الى
بورتسودان ومن بورسودان طبعا البعض مكث
لايام بانتظار دورهم لاجلائهم لان الاجلاء
يتم على دفعات الدفعات الاولى او الدفعه
الاولى من الاجلاء كانت تقتصر على
الرسميين البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الدبلوماسيين الاماميين ومن ثم المواطنين
طبعا واسرهم
اذا عمليه افراغ الطائره وانزال الركاب
بدات هي كما نتابع طائره حربيه
تابعه للسلطات الاردنيه لسلاح الجو
الاردني
عمليه الاجلاء هذه طبعا تتوازى مع عمليات
اجلاء اخرى ان كان عبر مطار الملك عبد
العزيز في جده الذي ايضا وصلت اليه كميات
كبيره من المواطنين ومن الطائرات ومن عفوا
اذا فلنستمع الى
تصريح لوزير الخارجيه ايمن الصفدي وزير
الخارجيه الاردني فلنستمع اليه
على ما يبدو بانه سيكون هناك تصريح فننتظر
التصريح هو طبعا باستقبال المواطنين
الاردنيين لا نعلم اذا كان هناك جنسيات
اخرى موجوده هذه الطائره ولكن هو باستقبال
من تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم الى
مطار ماركا في عمان
اذا كما نشاهد نساء واطفال
[موسيقى]
ينزلون بهذه الاثناء من الطائره العسكريه
الاردنيه
وايضا عسكريين كانوا موجودين على متن هذه
الطائره والذين هم ايضا يعني تولوا عمليه
الاجلاء التي اطلقت من بورسودان
نستمع قليلا
اذا
صحافه
اذا سمحت
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع واياكم عمليه
انزال الركاب
والمواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
نساء اطفال رجال موظفين يعني ينزلون تباعا
من الطائره الحربيه
باستقبالهم وفد رسميه راسها وزير الخارجيه
الاردني ايمن الصفدي
كما ذكرت هي الطائره الخامسه التي تصل الى
الاردن ضمن عمليات الاجلاء لا ارقام حتى
الساعه عن يعني اجمالي العدد الذين تم
اجلائهم من الخرطوم الى الاردن
وايضا لا ارقام عن من تبقى هناك ومن يعني
سيتم اجراءهم ايضا بالساعات المقبله لكن
المعلن حتى الساعه بان عمليات الاجلاء
ستستمر على الاقل في الساعات المقبله وفي
الايام المقبله لكل الراغبين بالخروج من
الخرطوم
اذا عمليات الاجلاء هذه
تستكمل بموازات الهدنه التي اعلن عنها
بالامس بعد اتصال حصل بين وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بلينكن وطرفي النزاع هناك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات